some days are more comfortable covering
my hair and other days I am more
comfortable showing it what I have heard
sister Dina Tokyo may Allah bless her is
that she has taken off their hijab oh
and I watch it now yeah
what skirt so you're just inviting
you're asking for trouble girls if you
walk down the street in the short skirt
day I was in the car being driven along
by one of my good male pals I noticed
his head swivel almost 360 degrees
obviously let's see what's he looking at
and it was the long long long long long
long legs of a girl getting off a school
bus why is it that women are being
punished why that's why I do why was
your comic writer why can't women be so
much a lot of Medicare to bother the
sisters we've got our letter post the
post is on time today insha'Allah
welcome to fuzzy to me introduce you
guys are Malaika welcome to the White
House this brought to you by Salam
studios inshallah there's a link at the
bottom please do support our works to
bring you guys more videos like this so
let's see what trouble our dear friends
got for us today in show us all we do is
we open the envelope we found out what
is our common question that's what
misconception us today and we discuss it
on the White House you know you guys
asked us to wise and we try to answer
them Salah so why do Muslim and have to
wear the hijab okay
interesting interesting very simple
we've done many videos on this which I
will link inshallah not to make it
repetitive but there's a thing that I
want to add on to this question is Allah
today which is that recently from what I
have heard that sister Dina Tokyo may
Allah bless her and guide her and guide
myself I mean always inshallah is that
she has taken off the hijab oh there is
certain days or something along that
line so what I'm going to do is in short
I'm gonna get straight into it I would
really encourage everybody that's
watching this please if you can just
stay tuned in and inshallah this will be
a very beneficial video for every single
one of us insha'Allah I don't know where
this was taken other it was Instagram I
don't know if it was snapshot dunno
where it was here
so this is apparently this is from
sister Dina trophy oh yeah may Allah
bless er there's been a lot of
speculation and madness over the weekend
regarding the regarding they okay the
way I've been wearing or not wearing my
headscarf I've always been very honest
with you guys and so for me sharing my
recent decisions with you it's just
natural just for context this is all
very new for me too
this is all very new for me too I've
only recently started showing my hair
over the past few months every now and
then whenever I have felt comfortable to
do so some days are more comfortable
covering my hair and other days I am
more comfortable showing it that's just
it let's get one thing straight
I still believe it's in head covering as
a part of my modesty and as a part of my
life and it will always be a part of me
it's a part of my heritage religion and
culture know no one can take that away
from me I have just decided that the
best thing for me personally is not to
commit to it daily that I have done for
the past 20 years that is all now
hearing this obviously it's it's
upsetting in a way for example like I'm
not this video is not about me
having a good system having a go at a
sister daughter sister Dina Tokyo and
saying how would you do that you know I
knew who's gonna do that he was heading
in that direction shame on you
you should be ashamed of yourself etc
etc me and Musa did a video about a year
ago to sister Dina Tokyo where she was
talking about that it's hard for her to
wear the hijab but for the love of Allah
she wears it and we put applauded her
for that you know Judy I'm Janice they
even don't like the certain things that
we do not agree with however as far as I
know she didn't she didn't really take
that lightly about anyways we did we did
our job you know I didn't they what we
did not do that video with a reaction
from or how how she thinks we just do it
because we genuinely care about her and
not only her but the people that follow
her and the people that follow us so we
did that video insha'Allah and you know
there was a comment that was given off
you know why are you giving the CEO to
somebody else's wife you know I think
sister Dina was referring to that you
know look of course
I don't need hear from you some of the
room knows I'm not and if I'm not
mistaken yeah um she's she's partially
right she's partially right but keeping
in mind that she's a public figure and
that she's out there and it is important
for us to do that like in a way we're
giving the scene only to her but also to
the people that are listening because
like it or not to my dear sister Dina
and myself we're in the same boat we are
a public figure and people do look up to
us so that does come with
responsibilities that doesn't mean it
shapes the way you live your life or
whatever but however because if you're
going through that phase in public it
has a ripple effect on the people that
follow you and a very recent well not
recent example an example I can give is
I was very very close to somebody who I
really was very closely with and I
stopped working with them because I
actually believe that they were causing
damage to the dawa unintentionally I
don't believe they intentionally were
doing it but an intention they were
causing a lot of damage and I looked a
lot of problems you know people have
endowed people taken any carbs of all
these kind of stuff that were happening
so I felt that person was causing damage
to the Dower
so that's what I had to free myself from
that not because I'm better than him or
he's better than me but because I felt
that thou has been portrayed in the
wrong way in the wrong manner in wrong
ways in harsh ways and I don't want to
go down that route and I that's not
within my character you know so that's
why I went my separate ways so it's just
to show you the reason I'm mentioning
this to you is to show you that we take
very seriously the following that people
that the people that follow us do get
I'm trying to say so I wanna run a
little tantrum but anyways now besides
point all of that yeah now my reaction
to that is obviously like I said before
it's sad to hear that you know and we
ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to make it
easy on her we have to assume the best
the cell of the Salaf assaleh him you
know when they would see their Brava
drenched in alcohol they would say maybe
this someone poured it poured it over
them poured it over
yeah so we need to make excuses we need
to make use now obviously this is a
public thing that the sisters doing is
it a sin yes it is a sin now when we say
we assume the best that means that we
assume the best our sister is going
through something or she's doing a
mistake whatever it may be however this
does not take the fact away from it
that what is being done is a sin and
doing in a public sphere
may cause other people to follow our
sister down that route so it is wrong
we're not gonna come and say it is right
it is wrong it is wrong inshallah but
this does not mean we're gonna
discourage you know and we hope that our
sister comes back insha'Allah comes back
stronger so now what I wouldn't address
mainly at this point is our sisters and
who watch sister Dina Tokyo yeah
now sister Dina talk to you from the
mistake she's made it very clear she's
not she doesn't come as a representative
of Islam yeah now - true that's true
she can't make that disclaimer but still
she's got some things on her shoulders
which is that she like it or not you are
a Muslim and as a Muslim community
Allah has expectations from you from
myself and the Muslim Ummah as a whole
now one thing that I want to share with
you guys is brothers and sisters is when
the prophet sallallaahu seldom died now
you're gonna be asked to me brother Ali
what's that got to do with anything
now I you guys said listen really really
carefully to me brother and sisters when
the prophet sallallaahu lay was seldom
died oh my Democrat table was enraged
this all of the Companions imagined The
Messenger of Allah who they lived ate
with drank with get everything with has
passed away it was a great blow and a
great shock to them America Thompson if
anybody says a allahu an but the
messenger of allah stifle Allah Allah
will send them I would kill them this is
how up say was Abu Bakr rajala and look
at the hikmah look at the wisdom well
why he bothers and sisters not what he
said and look how this connects Abu Bakr
then went out and found America table
and and talking to the people and said
Omar be seated Omar cartographers and
people parted oh man and came to Abu
Bakr and then our baccarat della and
cave gave his historical sermon he said
listen carefully and now this is from
the Quran he who worships Muhammad peace
be upon him Muhammad is dead now but he
who worships Allah Allah he is Allah
everliving and he never dies
Allah says Muhammad peace be upon him is
no more than a mess
ja and indeed and indeed many messengers
have passed away before him if he dies
or is killed will you then turn your
back on your heels as disbelievers and
he turns back on his heels not the least
harm will he do to Allah and Allah and
Allah will give reward to those who are
grateful now the reason I mention this
is brothers and sisters is a following
yeah now I'm gonna give myself as an
example if one day I decide and say you
know what I don't want to practice
anymore like may Allah protect me from
that well I'm a lost want to pretend I I
fear it yeah
let's say something I go down that night
what are you gonna do are you going to
stop practicing Islam I even say I was
only practicing called Ali da was
practicing it since I need that was
stopped it now I don't want to practice
anymore
well why this is wrong and this is what
Abu Bakr and Ilan said to the Companions
those of you those of you who worshipped
Muhammad sallallaahu Selim then know
that he is gone those of you who really
understood tawheed worshipping allah and
allah alone no partners no intercessors
not going through this person or that
person know that allah is all living is
everliving so my brothers and sisters
whoever it may be a public for a public
person just because sister Dina Tokyo
decided to take off her hijab
some people might go down the route and
say oh I'm gonna take off his role it is
very very important brothers and sisters
for us to not ever attach ourself to
people who have passed away
attach yourself to the people the
scholars who have passed away because we
know what they died upon I don't know
what I'm gonna die upon it's very
important for us to do this otherwise
we're gonna fall into a lot of problems
we yourself look you like on videos good
enjoy it like it benefit from me make
dua for us but do not make us some kind
of a yardstick where you measure
everything with Islam is the Huq the
Prophet SAW Allah send them smoke the
Huq and the Huq the chief comes from
allah subhanho wa taala
this is what you follow the Quran the
Sunnah and the way of the self
that's all you know the rest forget it
any doubt about the stray eyelid I was
going to a lead ours room it's time
the huh the unit OQ goes astray and the
Islam is the hot food it should go to
straight Islam is the hub Adam sila goes
astray
Islam is the Huq most demon goes astray
a thumb is the half saya - ghost astray
it goes astray Islam is the heart and I
couldn't carry on giving on brothers and
sisters
Islam is the hawk Islam is the hawk free
yourself from these people whoever it
may be
yeah because it's really important
because we are influential but this
doesn't mean you follow us with the room
that we do yeah I'm putting up in the
past when he heard this he said by Allah
it sounded as if people had never heard
such a parameters and Abu Bakr Adela Han
recited it as a reminder so people
started reciting it till there was no
man who did not recite it so see how a
benefit reminder a reminder benefits a
believer they acted like this verse
never existed subhanAllah when they
heard it they came back to their senses
and that's the reason why we give you
our reminders not that you do not know
but it might be that you've forgotten
and then remind the benefits a believer
like the prophets allah allah allah wa
sallam said if you guys remember a
couple of months ago i've done a video
which you can see on here called giving
muslim girls my phony experiment you
know where i went up two sisters and i
said can you read the sister i'll give
him the phone they're ready where was a
video of encouragement you know saying
system may Allah bless you guys for
wearing the hijab in this hot weather
may Allah grant you gender something
along those lines yeah it was
encouragement you know and this is what
this video is about this video is about
encouragement it's encouraging our
sisters you know just cause be a public
figure whoever is just because they
stopped doing something doesn't mean
you're going to go down that route you
have to be among the strong ones and
we're gonna come to you how the untidy
woman and how the the Sahaba at how they
were you know inshallah to see that so
Alice one that says in surah a sir
while a sir in El in Santa Fe Joseph
Allah Lavina a man over a me loose Ali
hearty what our Sobel hockey what our
sole miss summer by time everybody is in
loss except those who believe and do
righteous deeds and call each other to
truth and quote each other each other to
patience that is what I'm doing here
and sisters I'm here to encourage and
call you guys to treat and call you guys
to patients in Sharla we know it's hard
but inshallah be strong and inshallah
allah subhanho wa taala will make easy
for every single one of us go free tests
inshallah you know some people are gonna
come and say you know you're you know be
free like us you know free you know Lori
yokels are worth it you know in the
hands final and you got you know wind
blowing towards you you know and they
call that cell free I made out free
believe me they're not free every single
one of us are bound to be a slave slave
or something yeah one philosopher said
man is born free but chained in all
directions has chuckles all of them in
all directions yeah well we're trying to
what we're doing is this we're seeing
there's all these man-made laws all of
it yeah and every single person follow
something every single one of us follow
it something we're saying no yeah we're
saying when we say ashhadu an la ilaha
illallah WA ash hadu ana muhammadan
abduhu wa rasuluh when we say there is
nothing worthy of worship except Allah
we're saying to all the man-made laws
laws goodbye we are choosing to worship
Allah and Allah alone that's what we're
doing so for those who are saying we'll
free no you're not you are now in Chains
with man-made laws which they tell you
which is right wrong and today's society
it's about looking beautiful looking
like this and looking like that and
that's what you're following because
when I ask a lot of these girls who go
and where certain hills and I'm like are
you comfortable in that you're not your
heels are bleeding like this no you're
wearing that with blood sweat and tears
you're sweating you know sometimes you
cry and you're bleeding
don't tell me you're free when you have
eyelashes and make heart and lipstick
and you feel like oh I need to get a
breast job a whatever whatever here this
day you're not free you are a slave to a
society who's telling you what to do
whereas Muslim woman who there's people
who come to Islam as well they're seen
and we obey what our lords told us I
wanna tell you this we obey that so you
are not free
you are community-owned they're free
they're not they look and act a certain
way yet and for those who even vaguely
immediate test it but some of the time
sometimes it's the fact that they want
it wouldn't be a part of it they want to
be a part of their hair getting it done
etc I'm not saying this is just Edina
talking I'm just saying in general
sometimes sisters females they go down
that route because the temptation is too
much it's too much and specifically when
you don't understand your religion it
gets harder so for the woman who our
community are you're pressed they're
looking at you with the Goku's of the
21st century man-made laws that's been
given to them and there's you know
you're oppressed excuse me you're
pressed you want you your body the way
your address is in affiliation or it's
that you have a your body's being used
for chocolate for car for engine for
light bowls for laptops what has your
body got to do with the chocolate with a
car with a light bulb with a laptop what
no because it attracts attention we're
going to use you you have become a
sexual object and you're being used and
you're looking at a Muslim woman and
saying was a woman our first they they
are saying no we're not going to go down
that route of being sexually exploited
you know used you know and we are going
to obey our Lord and cover ourselves now
let's talk about when is Alice Pantera
asked all of us to wear the hijab is
very important I'm not gonna get
straight into it go to surah noor verse
24 the verse 31 and tell the believing
woman to lower their gaze and protect
their private parts from illegal sexual
acts and not to show off their adornment
except only that which is apparent like
both which is apparent Nessa Nessa
sister see the way or outer part of her
and to draw their veils all over their
do Rubina yeah over their bosoms yeah
surah surah ahzaab verse 59 all profit
tell your wives and your daughters and
the woman of the believers to draw their
clothes veils all over their bodies
screen themselves completely that will
be better that they should be known so
as as a respectful respectful woman as
not to be annoyed and Allah is
oft-forgiving very merciful also we have
a hadith ya from the prophet sallallaahu
Selim
it was narrated from Safia been shy
saber that i
anher may allah be pleased with her used
to say when these words were reviewed
and to draw their veils all over your
bosoms they took their is ours
a kind of garment and told them from the
edges and covered their faces with them
yeah another way I went from our doubt
may I love mercy on the mahajan woman
when Allah reviewed the words and draw
their veils all over their bosoms they
tore the thickest part of the aprons and
garments and covered their faces with
them yeah now another thing is that if
I'm mistaken the unsightly woman yeah
the woman of the un-- sorry when they
heard this verse you know what they did
they came and toured their garments
ripped it off and they say that
unsightly woman were known to have thick
hair yeah the hair would just you know
come out and they would automatically
cover their selves now we can talk about
the wisdom look I'm looking really talk
about the wisdom of why there are lost
funds are legislated this you know why
Darla legislated this the question here
is this when Allah stepped down the
revelation in surah Noor a sort of zap
none of these women come and said hold
on I said all this it can't give me a
second myself I want to know why why why
does Allah want me to wear none of them
they heard and they listened now there
is business behind it we're not seeing
that you know we can talk about the
wisdoms yeah but the issue here is is
that they were so dedicated that as soon
as they heard it they said look did
Allah say that didn't Allah say that yes
okay that's all I need to know they went
and ripped their garments now brothers
and sisters My dear sisters it is very
important for all of us to educate our
self for promises well about the
religion I came across a so-called
ex-muslim once again who doesn't know
the basics I asked him what do you study
gos philosophy I said it's philosophy
that's caused you to leave Vista because
I said to he was going skeptical about
everything I'll send him is there a
transport as a transfer in I said is
there a chance that I'm a lamppost again
he said yeah there's a chance this is
your lamppost and since they charge you
a red dinosaur there's a chance I'm a
retired so if only I said see we've only
spent ten percent of the time and
dedication that you give the philosophy
to Islam you would have not be where you
are today buffer we do not take the time
out and study
religion and when these doubts come and
these desires got thrown at us what do
we do we have to resubmit why because we
are not equipped with the knowledge
study your religion brothers and sisters
won't lie it's so important for us to
study our religion Allah did not say to
the woman cover up because men can't
lower their gaze yeah I love did you not
see this yeah both men and woman order
to cover up and they said they might be
a lot of witness behind this yeah many
many voices behind first its
distinguished to believe in men I mean
the believer woman from the ones who are
none Muslim in distinguished yes very
distinguished very class distinguished
so when you look at the Catholic woman
you know they have a specific side well
you look at the Jewish woman they have a
specific sign this for the Muslim woman
a specific sign now one of the wisdoms
may be that for example when you cover
yourself my dear sisters yeah and you
cover yourselves for example sisters you
wearing a card or your communist off and
if you wear chill bar blues clothing
properly what happens is that when a man
is speaking to you they are looking at
your face they are talking to you they
are not looking elsewhere because
there's nothing to look at now this is
the psychology this is how a man is
created like it or not there is actually
video from the morning the good morning
show from the mistake I'm gonna play for
you guys right now watch it now yeah
skirt so you're just inviting you're
asking for trouble girls if you walk
down the street in short skirt well I
come from the school that says a woman
should be able to wear anything she
wants to wear and why shouldn't she and
it's got nothing to do with you watching
her are you over there judging her if
she wants to wear a niqab or he dubs you
should be able to wear that if she wants
to wear the shorter shorts in the
shorter skirts she should be able to
wear that and then I come to the bit
where I have to say but and I don't
really want to say that because I
believe women should be able to wear
whatever they like but the other day I
was in the car being driven along by one
of my good male pals I noticed his head
swivel almost 360 degrees obviously
let's see what's he looking at and it
was the long long long long long long
legs of a girl getting off a school bus
that's how I know she was a school girl
she had gorgeous long legs and she was
wearing the shortest shorts I think I've
ever seen almost embedded in her
buttocks and yes I defend her right to
wear those shorts wherever she likes why
shouldn't she and yet I saw the head
swivel of a very good friend of mine and
I
suddenly couldn't help thinking in the
real world where people don't behave
necessary as you wish they would we know
what we ought to do but we know what
people do do and if this was my little
girl he was working he was doing just
that
so do you see that is a lady who's
saying that she saw her own driver
his eyes great gazing away why because
we are told about Elena's messenger the
biggest weakness for a man is a woman
hands down you can rip your hair about
it you can get your Chanel bag and - it
your lipstick whatever it's not going to
change the biggest weakness for a man is
a woman this does not mean that I'm
trying to say that the ones who wear
hijab or abaya
will not get raped no the ones who rape
they don't really like I believe a rape
you wear hijab don't wear hijab which
one is more he prone would go for I
don't know that what I'm saying to you
very clearly is that I'm not trying to
say where the hijab is told you don't
get raped I'm not saying that a rapist
will rape yeah some of them who have
fetishes with women that wear the hijab
yes some of them yeah so what I'm trying
to say to you is that is that there is
wisdoms behind it you know because if
you go down the street go and go and
there was even a thing of catcalling
yeah so many women get harassed on a
daily basis on a daily basis Spina what
Allah has given it for a reason yeah to
protect your modesty to show that you're
a Muslim a Muslim woman yeah
in hijab and for those who say the job
is not in the Quran please yeah the word
khimar is there yeah Hammad is a very
simple head it's talking about your head
that's what it's talking about it's like
me saying is that me giving you socks
where does the socks belong and your
feet you're never the computer on your
head or your hand unless you've lost the
plot this belongs to your feet just the
way SMR for example another word that we
know is hammer how many alcohol yeah why
is it because it's like hammer is
alcohol yeah and what does alcohol do it
covers your judgment hammer yeah
if comedy intoxicates you you know you
don't you can distinguish between right
or wrong
covers your judgment even some of the
Arabs when they would see a horse that
has got different color for example is
brown on the body and from the neck on
with his wife they would say for example
they would use a word like motor humming
motor humming yeah they would say look
it looks like he's the horse is wearing
a hijab and they would even call their
own own head covering him are the men
who used to wear it well unless one time
I seen is true the woman there too
because the woman back in the Jaya days
they would all cover their hair hands
down it was that was a default position
but they would have its dangling on the
back unless want Alice said take that
and cover your bosoms Muslims yeah okay
so the word M R is there Jill Bab is
there it's very clear so anybody trying
to sugarcoat it and no it doesn't mean
that we start a video with Muhammad
hijab and Moosa on this video nearly got
half a million views you can watch a
lady who was trying to justify and no
it's not here for today you know and we
brought the evidences you know it's
really important now this another issue
is brothers and sisters I mean wrapping
up in Java anybody comes and says oh I
took the hijab off because hijab is not
mentioned in the Quran or it's not
mentioned here that I'm sorry you're
kidding yourself because the society
that we live in having long hair doing
your hair coloring your hair all that is
temptation you cannot deny it you cannot
light yourself and say no that's not
some tation that is temptations with its
temptation for you it is so to come and
say no it's I took of my hijab because I
liberated myself or freedom is nonsense
is absolutely I'm sorry it's nonsense oh
I'm not doing it for myself okay why are
you dressed up in a certain way so guys
that's about it for me and the wife I
hope you guys have loved this program
this new show in shala subscribe and
more videos will come in where we debunk
every single misconception and answers
that are fraud about Islam about the
prophet sallallaahu will sell them keep
tuning in sha la - next time from the
yfiles
keep the Y's coming in cuz we've got the
answers for you assalamualaikum
warahmatullah better here too